mind your decisions I'm presh tall
Walker consider the equation ax squared
minus 5x plus 2 is equal to 0 solve for
a such that the equation has exactly one
solution this is from the finished
matriculation exam in 2014 which had an
award of 1000 euros for a perfect score
some students missed the award by
missing this problem I saw this on
reddit math pause if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we can solve a quadratic equation using
Brahma goop this quadratic formula X is
equal to the opposite of B plus or minus
the square root of b squared minus 4ac
all over 2a since we don't want to
divide by zero a cannot be equal to zero
this formula represents two different
solutions we'll separate them out into
x1 and x2 we'll get a single solution if
the discriminant b squared minus 4ac is
equal to zero in that case the
discriminant will vanish and the square
root term will vanish
so both of the solutions will be equal
to negative B over 2a
we'll use this lesson to solve our
problem we'll substitute in the values
and then we'll set B squared minus 4ac
to be equal to zero this simplifies to
be 25 minus 8 a is equal to zero which
we can easily solve that a is equal to
twenty-five over eight many people
thought this was the answer but this is
not the complete answer to the problem
remember this is only true if a is not
equal to zero so we need to separately
consider the case if a is equal to zero
in that case we reduce this into a
linear equation which of course has just
one solution X is equal to two over five
so this is the complete solution a is
equal to twenty-five over eight or a is
equal to zero I also think it's fun to
visualize this problem let's plot this
equation for a is equal to two we get a
parabola which has two x-intercepts
which are the two solutions as we varied
the parameter a this parabola will just
become tangent to the x axis and have
one solution this occurs when b squared
minus 4ac is equal to zero and we get a
is equal to twenty-five over eight now
if we vary this parameter a and let it
go to zero this parabola will eventually
become a linear equation at a is equal
to zero
and this will give us one solution the
other solution will be when the
discriminant is equal to zero and a is
equal to 25 over 8 I think it's a very
neat problem and it really tests your
understanding of quadratic equations
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you